foreign
Ventura what's up Tim
hey Dr John how are you I'm good man how
are you
good good I'm uh I'm really grateful to
be on I'm a long time listener and you
give great advice so that's why I'm
calling in well you're awesome hope I
can uh hope I can keep the keep the
trend going dude what's up
yeah I had a general question and we can
dig into specific details if it helps
out okay but my question is this what
does it mean when you say you need to
grieve and what I mean by that is
uh sometimes when someone like me is
going through you know life issues
and and it's and we're thinking oh I
wish life were like this I wish life
were like that if I wish you know I had
this kind of relationship with my family
and I listened to your show and you say
well you're living a fantasy you need to
learn how to grieve that loss and and
move on and I'm thinking that that
sounds great Dr John but what does that
mean you know what is what does grieving
look like exactly dude that's a great
question
um
do you have an example of something that
we could use as as kind of a model to
work through
yeah so I'm married to a wonderful woman
16 years we have a five-year-old son
and part of me wishes we could have two
children but even having one was tough
enough and what was tough about it
so four years it took us four years to
even get pregnant and then we had a
miscarriage in the second trimester uh
it took another four years
to have this child a miracle child he's
his name's Kyle he's a ball of energy we
love him to death and we we just
couldn't go through you know trying
another you know couple of years for for
a second and I guess one fantasy I'm
holding on to is I really wish we had a
second child
and it's like no we I gotta grieve that
loss but I just don't know I just don't
know what that means so let's replace
the word grief for a minute with the
word
experience
and when we use the word experience
instead of grief
we're gonna be swimming Upstream against
a cultural current that is so powerful
and here's what that cultural current is
feeling sad is something that you need
to fix
wishing and wanting something and
admitting it's not going to happen is
for losers and quitters for people who
don't want it bad enough
um
wishing something was different is is
ungrateful you should just be happy with
whatever you got
and so when I say that I want someone to
grieve the purpose of grief is
experience
for a moment sometimes and sometimes for
a long season
because I don't care what anybody says
if you lose a child there's no silver
lining
there's no
um God needed another Angel crap or
whatever stupid things get stitched on
pillows of people try to say in your
case
that now that you in this this happened
to me it took us four years to have Hank
Okay and then we had several
gnarly miscarriages this whole thing and
um then Josephine comes out of nowhere
okay so a similar track
um as you guys were on
I didn't understand that I had the
capacity for love and joy like I did
until I held my son
I didn't get it and especially um I
won't even be one of those dads it's
like as soon as I hugged him I knew I
didn't I mean it was just like a yelling
lump of uh screaming human it it evolved
over six months nine months a year right
and so I've had the same thing too
like the thought of of just having had
Easter and we have three or four
Knuckleheads running around like sounds
amazing and it's not gonna happen
it's not gonna happen so everything in
our culture says move on be grateful
don't be a whiner what grief is choosing
to sit for a minute or a an hour or a
day or a season
and just be heartbroken
let your body catch up to your spirit
how does that sound
it sounds it sounds good
but I I you know still more questions
come up bring them up bring them all on
bring everything because all the
questions you have are going to be
really helpful to people who are
listening yeah so so when I hear that I
I'm thinking you know how do I know if
I'm being successful at experiencing or
grieving how do I know it's not a
competition it's great there's grieving
is not a competition
uh people who compare grief my great
he's a extraordinary therapist his name
is link he's a he's a close friend of
mine and he was one of my crisis team
partners
um
he lost uh pregnancy
um that that him and his wife lost her
pregnancy later on than my wife and I
lost one of ours and I remember saying
to him
um
like I was so heartbroken and it was a
mess and in our home and I told him but
man I don't know anything about what
y'all went through and he looked at me
and said no no no no loss is lost you
don't compare grief
right so there's in grief as the great
David Kessler says uh it's
indistinguishable if it's it's I'm sorry
it's um unique
every everybody's grief is is like a
fingerprint it's different for everybody
and that's one of the things that breaks
up marriages is after six months
sometimes after the somebody loses a
parent after six months one of the
partners is like all right I'm ready
let's go do something fun
and then the other person looks at him
and just how could you possibly breathe
I'm not there yet right and that's hard
it's hard so to answer your question
there's not a right or wrong way there's
a couple of practices you can build in
there but
if you're looking for it to be the
answer to all things it won't be what it
does is um you ever been out in the
ocean swimming before
yep so you know when you're swimming out
in the ocean and also you can't touch
anymore and you're trying to like touch
touch touch touch and it you your heart
just starts beating a little bit faster
and then you start kicking your legs you
start kicking your arms a little bit and
then all of a sudden there's that moment
when your foot touches the ground
that's that's what grief gives you it
gives you Solid Ground to walk on again
you're still up to your neck and water
it's not like this person's coming back
it's not like suddenly your house is
going to be filled with people but you
can touch again and then you get to
figure out what we're gonna do next
okay and then how do I know when I'm
done grieving like I often I hear you
say well you do you you need to write a
letter to your to the child that is was
never meant to be or you know picking up
bricks and you know putting masking tape
on it writing your you know writing
something on there and putting in your
backyard I'm like am I supposed to be
doing those things so in order to
complete the grieving process I think
it's incredibly important to have a
process and a a
for lack of better terms a ceremony
something to point back to
I have the names of the the babies that
we lost pregnancy all three of them
tattooed on my body and I did it on my
ribs where it would hurt the worst
and my wife and I had a small thing that
we did just very privately that I won't
talk about anymore
but all I have to say is I have a you
have a touchstone now that's why every
single culture has some sort of
um
funeral some sort of honoring of the
Dead some form of honoring the passing
of
because you have to have a place to
Market
and that's why I'm really adamant that
that people take their kid parents take
their kids to funerals because it just
leaves an ellipsis it leaves a dot dot
dot on their life on relationships and
kids it's just a it's Mayhem so yeah
when I tell somebody to write a letter
when I tell somebody to carry a brick
around when I tell somebody to do a
thing but I'm trying to give them is a
tangible moment in history that they
will always be able to point back to
this is when I put a period at the end
of the sentence that was this person's
life this is what I put a period into
the sentence of this job of this breakup
of this marriage of this whatever of
this dream I had
this is when I said this isn't gonna
happen
I'm gonna take another route but it's
good to always have a place to point
back to
so when here's how I I tell people quote
unquote you're done grieving I don't
know that you're ever gonna not wish
that something was different here's the
difference I know people are ready to
move on when their bodies no longer
react to the story
does that make sense that makes that
makes sense so let's and then like let
me just for people listening
um
there was a season when I couldn't talk
about
um especially the third after the third
one I couldn't talk about miscarriages
couldn't talk about them
um I couldn't uh I don't want to talk
about them I don't want to discuss them
I didn't want to bring them up
uh cause my wife so much pain it caused
so much chaos in my house I felt so
inadequate because I didn't know what to
do I don't know what to say
um I was trying to solve all my wife's
problems with charts and graphs it was
just a mess and so I didn't know what to
do
and so I just didn't want to talk about
it
once we sat down once I sat down went
through a formal grieving process I
entered into a season of sadness
I thought my life was gonna look
different and I thought these three were
gonna be a part of it and they're not
um now I'm at a place where I talk about
a lot from a teacher I can make meaning
of it and the meaning I'm going to make
of it is I'm going to teach people
here's how to how to do life when it
gets sideways on you so my body doesn't
take off on me anymore my heart rate
doesn't start beating I don't get that
warm weird heavy feeling in my stomach I
don't feel like I'm gonna just start
crying without it right so my body's not
taken off on me that's how that's
usually how people know but you're never
gonna not wish
is someone you love wasn't still with
you that's never going to go away
and what are some exercises that I can
practice where if I feel myself drifting
back into
that fantasy that that thing that I
thought I had finished grieving if I
feel like creeping up
what can I do to kind of interrupt that
that thought
so
um this is again from the great David
Kessler I think everybody who's
interested in learning more about grief
the greatest book I've ever read been a
part of seeing anything and I've been a
part of it I wasn't a part of it but
I've ever read I've I've I've probably
sold him a lot of books because I I'm
always giving it away and recommending
it to everybody it's called finding
meaning by David Kessler
um it's just a masterpiece when it comes
to grieving one of the key takeaways for
me in that book
um was this idea that
we are we we culturally we are beholden
to our thoughts and our feelings
we have to do whatever they say they get
to rule our world so if I feel a certain
way or if a thought just pops into my
head or in your case let's say you're
you're going to a ball field with your
with your you have a son or daughter
have a son okay so y'all are going to
play little league and you are walking
and you see a dad pile out of a junkie
Minivan and he's got four little kids
and a fifth one is a little bit older
and your heart just drops a little bit
that moment
I always thought that
I just I I didn't know there was another
alternative to that
and so one of the things Kessler talks a
lot about and I've taken what he taught
and I've taught it to a ton of people
who are like the last picture they have
of their kid is the funeral
the last picture they have of their
spouse is the funeral and like a
lightning bolt those pictures will zap
into their head or somebody who is
happily married and then their spouse
comes home and says I cheated on you
they have this image of their partner
with somebody else and it just shoots
into their mind like a lightning bolt
they can't get that picture I mean they
can't stop that picture from shooting in
there the moment you feel yourself
starting to feel that again that's the
moment you have a choice
and usually the best thing to do is have
two things by your side number one a
picture to reinsert instead of the one
that just popped into your mind not the
picture of you sitting around an empty
Thanksgiving table but the picture of
you chasing your son around the yard
with him laughing and screaming in that
waddling wonky run that little babies do
the second thing is have a train of
thought a mantra a thing that you say
that is going to redirect your thoughts
in another Direction sometimes I'll be
walking through you've heard me say on
the show I'll be walking through the
house and I'll just yell out no I'm not
doing that I'm not having this
conversation with myself
I'm a blessed guy
I'm really blessed
and so I've got to step into those
thoughts and decide I want to disrupt
them it feels really good
to not good it doesn't feel good like
like a massage or like laughter and joy
but it's seductive to go down that dark
path and to say what if and maybe if I
had a different wife or if my wife had
been different if I had just done these
things differently if it's just
seductive to go down that route for a
hundred different reasons but it doesn't
serve anything because it's not reality
absolutely yeah that's something I am
working on myself with exactly what you
said and I guess um I'll end with this
are the five stages of grief real are
those feelings or
you know um are those things that you
have to experience to for grief to kind
of run its course or I'm not really too
sure about that yeah they're I like the
I've heard it said they're descriptive
not prescriptive
meaning it's a framework
but there's there's been research that
suggests they're no good
um for me they give me
um they're like floaties in the ocean
uh when I'm grieving something some in
in like we have words like for anger
well anger for me is a whole process
right it's a whole day
and then sometimes I'm grieving
something little like I wanted to be
there on time so I could meet my
daughter when she got out of school I'm
not gonna make it I'm not angry I'm kind
of sad
I'm kind of pissed off that I have a job
that had a deadline that I couldn't
right or denial like some people go
through wild denial right they start
going to do laundry of their husband who
passed away and they folding clothes and
put them in the drawers right and then
some people's denial is like I just
don't want to look at that paper because
I know it's in I know that's the death
certificate I don't want to see it so I
think they're good touchstones but
anybody who's like looking to do a
checklist for grief is going to be
disappointed because the grief doesn't
work like that
so maybe the best gift I could give you
is this
you sound like an analytical guy you
sound like a guy who wants to make sure
he's doing things the right way and
honoring his wife and honoring himself
and honoring his child and honoring
whatever situation you're grieving
um and the way you do that in your work
life in your regular life and I may be
out to lunch here but so tell me if I'm
wrong but the way you do that is you
make sure you account for all the
variables
you're probably great in Excel is that
right
yeah you hit around the head like my
Myers Briggs on my stj Enneagram six
Super security Focus there you go so
here's what here's what uh grief looks
like for you
open both hands
and hold them as high as you can
let go
what you're trying to do is control a
tidal wave
and you can't
you gotta let it wash over you and it
feels like grief will kill you and it
won't
it feels like it will drown you it feels
like it will take you out to sea and it
won't
the last thing I'll leave you with is
this dude and again thank you so much
for these probing questions these are
really important important questions and
they're ones I need to do a better job
of explaining on the show sometimes I
just blow by some of the stuff because
I've been through it so much
you cannot under any circumstances this
is physiological this is psychological
this is spiritual emotional whatever Al
Word you want to attach to this
you cannot
do grief alone
as David Kessler says grief Demands a
witness
so sitting down in front of somebody
else and reading the letter you wrote to
the kid that you're not going to ever
have
that's when the healing Journey Begins
telling somebody I really wanted this
marriage to work and you cheated on me
and it's over now
that's when Healing Begins
grief demands a witness you gotta have
other people in your life that you can
talk to
thank you so much for the call Tim
you've just helped a whole bunch of
people by being vulnerable and open